we told you earlier about an emergency
session of the un human rights council
after it had received a letter from 300
mps in myanmar accusing the
junta there of gross violations the u.n
human rights council has unanimously
adopted
a british eu resolution on myanmar
calling for the release of aung san
tsuchi
and others arbitrarily detained
it urged the military and myanmar to
lift all restrictions on
internet telecommunications uh
as well and to exercise restraint
with protesters let's bring in al
jazeera's rory challenge who's been
following this emergency meeting from
brighton in the uk
rory uh what more do we know
yeah well i mean the the the human
rights council
was meeting in a special session that
was called by the
uk and the eu together acting in concert
and uh we had been hearing a whole range
of voices
the different ambassadors from many
countries giving their perspective
on what's been going on in myanmar
recently throughout the day
the draft resolution which had been
orally amended
to take in certain concerns that china
had had was was adopted unanimously it
was a
47 member
agreement essentially with a few
voices of of objection there was russia
which says that it wants to dissociate
itself with with this uh
resolution uh draft resolution there was
um
uh venezuela that has also said the same
and unsurprisingly myanmar itself
what the resolution essentially does is
is
say that the situation in myanmar as it
currently is
uh is unacceptable that's the
military authorities there have to
release people that they've been
detaining that
uh they need to roll back on
on the the takeover of power essentially
and that they
they have to let in uh and
to do more work that the un human rights
council's
special rapporteur um who was speaking
earlier on at this session so
i think the the russians the chinese the
venezuelans etc
uh are lone voices really
in what has been a pretty unified
position from the human rights council
and
its many of its members which is
essentially the
the what what has been going on in
myanmar as a gross violation of human
rights
al jazeera's rory challenge reporting
live there rory many thanks indeed